the rule of law and standing up to the
president anyone who cares about the
rule of law in this country is nauseated
by the fact that the president has
commuted the sentence of someone who
willfully lied to Congress House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi telling CNN that the
president's decision represents
staggering corruption people should know
this isn't just about lying to Congress
that means lying to the American
a William bar telling ABC's Pierre
Thomas stones 40 month sentence was fair
he was prosecuted while I was Attorney
General I think the prosecution was
righteous
but now stone will not serve a single
day of that prison sentence
Alex per se ABC News
you
what we've gone through that you are
exactly right mayor what you are saying
and what you are advocating you know
it's no longer a question of theory or
question of politics we have facts we
have data we went through it here in New
York we went through it in a worst case
scenario and it is about following the
data and following the science and
taking the precautions and doing what's
right
it is about masks masks work we can tell
you that here in New York we are the
worst spike per capita on the globe and
we brought it down and now you see these
other states are going higher than New
York so those masks work we were the
first state to start mandatory masks
April 15th and all the science now says
for sure masks make a big difference one
of the models last week the IH m e
models the gates funded model that the
White House uses actually projected
40,000 more Americans will die if we
don't have a national mask policy so
it's clear but we just wanted to tell
you that we feel for you we are all one
with one community I applaud your
leadership you really get to see what an
elected official is made of when the
when the pressure is on and you have
more than risen to the occasion you've
been inspired they refer to you as a
rising star and they are all correct and
we are with you anything we can do for
you or the city we stand ready we
remember how good the people across this
country were to us when we were in the
midst of it I asked for volunteers from
across the United States nurses doctors
to come help in our hospitals 30,000
people volunteered to come to new
New York in the midst of it and work in
our hospitals it was such an act of
generosity and love that it was really
touching so we're here for you concept
of pay forward whatever we can do on any
level we have people who've been through
this and actually know and we stand
ready but you're right
keep going stay strong the facts will
bear out it's about saving lives and
you're doing exactly the right thing and
the numbers are going to show that so
thank you for taking some time to be
with us today
across the country and at the beginning
of this pandemic my charge to my team
was simple god bless the child who's got
it sewn and I had no idea that we would
have to go it alone in so many ways I
thought that it was more geared towards
the lack of leadership we had at the
federal level but it has proven to be
equally challenging at the statewide
level and my family is an example of
what's happening across this country we
had an asymptomatic child in our home
for eight days before we knew that that
child was asymptomatic and by that time
my husband and I had contracted Kovac
unnecessarily I would imagine because we
would have taken precautions to protect
ourselves thankfully by the grace of God
we don't have underlying health
conditions and we are all on the mend my
husband is feeling a lot better but for
so many people across this country that
is not their story and their outcome is
so very different
so in Atlanta when we saw that we were
in a very different place than the
governor's leadership was taking us we
convened an advisory committee in our
city comprised of health experts small
business owners fortune 500
representatives colleges and
universities just really a
representation of our community and they
made some very clear recommendations on
where we needed to go with reopening a
phased approach we had made it into the
second phase but given where we are our
ICU bed capacity is maxed out in some
hospitals by the day we're getting
closer to maxing now in others
our numbers are kicking up I look at the
numbers daily I am seeing numbers that I
have not seen since April as of
yesterday afternoon we were up almost 23
percent over a week's period of time
we're headed in the wrong direction so
as a city we recommend it if we go back
to phase 1 which is essentially a stay
at home order also we've instituted
a masked man day the benefit of that is
is one us taken a very clear position as
a city that we recognize that mask
wearing mask helps save lives but also
even in the world's busiest airport
hartsfield-jackson Atlanta International
Airport one of our largest job centers
we can also mandate masks there as well
and it's very simple unless we have a
coordinated approach across this country
we are going to continue to
unnecessarily watch people done what
makes it even more frustrating and and
even more disappointing we didn't have
to look to Italy we could look to New
York and you told us very clearly that
if we didn't do things differently in
our cities and states we will find
ourselves in the same situation that
York was facing and unfortunately you
were correct because throughout the
South especially we are we are getting
there in rapid order and so I I thank
you for your leadership I know that as a
city in the same way New York was able
to get to the other side I know that we
will get to the other side but it is
going to take us taking responsibility
for ourselves and taking actions that
look at data and science and not just
our opinions Wow thank thank you very
much mayor and you're right the
unfortunate and really frustrating point
here is why did other states have to go
through this I mean we knew what we were
dealing with New York
went down the path before we lived
exactly this just learn from what New
York did learn from the numbers learn
from the data and we we knew that if you
reopen recklessly the virus was going to
take off again if you're not doing
precautions the virus was going to take
off now New York's problem is we have
the infection coming from other states
back to New York we're worried about our
infection rate going up because of
people coming from others
dates where the infection rate is higher
we have a cluster of cases in an upstate
County called Rensselaer people came up
from Georgia they had the virus and they
infected people in New York and then it
took off so you are you're on exactly
the right track anything we can do to
help we're at a stable period now we
have the virus way down low we went from
the worst infection rate in the country
to the best infection rate the lowest so
we have a little breathing space here
anything we can do for you that you need
any help on the testing setting up the
taste testing and the tracing that is so
so important and we've been through that
so you have an open offer whatever you
need but we're also 100% behind you and
we wish you Godspeed in your health
recovering and we hope that Atlanta
under your guidance comes back quickly
and anything we can do we stand ready
Thank You governor and that's exactly
what we need assistance with testing
testing that gets people's results very
quickly and also the contact tracing
because we know that's extremely
important for us to help slow the spread
so I appreciate your offer to help and
and we certainly would be appreciative
of that assistance well we can do that
we have I'll arrange it with your with
your team but we'll put together people
who've done a testing for us in the
contact tracing we actually worked with
Mike Bloomberg
former mayor of New York City and
because nobody knew what a contact
tracing program was and and we worked
with the former mayor who stepped up and
brought Johns Hopkins to the table and
we came up with a training program and a
whole software program so I'll send the
team down to Atlanta and they can work
with your people and whatever we know
and whatever we can share
we will do in the meantime send my
regards to the former mayor there who I
worked with send my regards to all the
people at senti Centennial Park when I
was HUD secretary I did a lot of work in
Atlanta a lot of good work I have a lot
of fond memories so send my regards to
everyone
I'll get that team together and they'll
come down to Atlanta as soon as it works
for you thank you for being with me I
appreciate it thank you my pleasure
Thanks okay
Godspeed to the mayor where are we today
is day 135 let's talk about some facts
first where are we 792 hospitalizations
today that is very good news Louis since
March 18th you look at our rate of
transmission all across the board every
region we see good numbers and again we
have more data than any state in the
country so we live and die by the data
and all the numbers are good you look
across New York City the County numbers
they are all good and they are all
consistent you have a little deviation
from day to day that's statistically
irrelevant but there's all good news in
the numbers across the state and of
course the city death toll for yesterday
is 10 people again we'd love to see that
number at zero but compared to where we
have been that is a very good place to
be you look at the three-day average and
you see there the whole slope of what
we've gone through you see the dissent
and the experts say to me you'll never
really get to zero on the number of
deaths because people die this is a
condition like the Moon pneumonia it
attacks the respiratory system so people
who are very ill can contract
and it can be the cause of death but
that's where we are now we did 51,000
tests yesterday and it was just over 1%
so it is all good news on where we are
as the state and the numbers show that
what we have done in terms of our
reopening strategy and our plan has
worked
we have been reopening for weeks now
over one month we started reopening and
we expected after the reopening we
expected the numbers to take up they
haven't picked up they've actually gone
down so the reopening strategy has
worked New York State Smart has worked
and it shows that this nation can defeat
Kovan there was no reason to have these
states on the increase
New York inherited a spike remember
where we started we were handed this
high infection rate because nobody knew
the virus had come from Europe so we
started with a high spike we had to get
that spike down the other states didn't
start with the spike they just had to
stop it from increasing and with all we
did in New York and all we knew they
were just blind to the reality and again
I want to congratulate New Yorkers who
really stepped up to the plate and they
did what they had to do and it was hard
social distancing closed businesses
closed schools stay at home it was hard
but they did it we now get to the
question of reopening schools there is a
state formula that will determine if it
is safe to reopen schools okay so open
schools or not there's a state formula
that determines it
they were then state guidelines
as to as to how that school reopens
right state formula determines if it
reopens if it reopens the second
question is how and that will be done by
state guidelines but the question of
school opening is like the question of
reopening the economy reopening the
schools reopening the economy is the
same conversation and by the way it's
the exact same conversation with the
President of the United States we talked
about reopening the economy and he said
just reopen just reopen the economy
there's no reason for any of this stuff
phases data mass it's all baloney just
reopened yeah we saw how will that work
go s Florida and Texas and Arizona how
will that work on schools what does he
say reopen the schools just open them up
don't worry
yeah he was wrong on the economic
reopening he's wrong on the schools
reopening everybody wants to reopen the
schools I want to reopen the schools
everybody wants to reopen the schools
it's not do we reopen or not you reopen
if it is safe to reopen how do you know
if it's safe you look at the data you
don't hold your finger up and feel the
wind you don't have an inspiration you
don't have a dream you don't have an
emotion look at the data we test more we
have more data than any state look at
the data if you have the virus under
control reopen if you don't have the
virus under control then you can't
reopen right we're not gonna use our
children as the litmus test and we're
not going to put our children in a place
where their health is endangered it's
that simple common sense and
intelligence can still determine what we
do even in this crazy environment we're
not going to use our children as guinea
pigs
I say to the experts is very simple if
I'm making the determination as to
whether or not I would send my daughter
to school if it's safe I'll send her if
it's not safe I'm not going to send her
and you can determine that by science so
the formula is this schools will reopen
if that region is in phase 4 and the
daily infection rate remains 5 percent
or lower over a 14 day average okay
you're in phase 4 and you're under 5%
infection rate that means the virus is
under control that means it's safe to
reopen and then the schools can proceed
to reopening in that region exactly how
you look at the state guidelines this
determination will be made the first
week in August second question is what
happens if between the first week in
August and the day school opens the
virus spikes I don't want to be in a
position where we made a determination
August 7th and then the virus spikes but
we already said the schools are going to
reopen so the safety valve there's a
floor schools will close if the regional
infection rate is above 9% on a
seven-day average okay so you get a
green light reopen in a region if you're
in phase 4 and the infection rate is 5%
or lower if the infection rate goes over
9% on a seven-day average that means the
virus is moving rapidly and it is not in
intelligent to open that's the green
light and that's the red light and it's
the way we've done the economic
reopening it's purely on the numbers
purely on the numbers it's on the
science will make the first decision the
numbers the week of August one to seven
the week because it's a rolling 14-day
average different regions are in
different positions on the 14-day
average between August first you get a
green light on August first
between August first and the day the
school opens we continue to monitor
every day and if the infection rate goes
over nine then we hit an emergency stop
button okay it's very simple it's clear
once you get a green light to reopen
then how you reopen you follow the
guidelines and we leave it to the 700
school districts across the state to
come up with the specific plan for suing
to those guidelines we have done state
health guidelines the State Department
of Education is doing state education
guidelines which will incorporate our
health guidelines we had a great
reimagine education Advisory Council
that did a lot of work to come up with
the guidelines Jim mellitus ran it for
me I want to thank them all very much
for the good work they did their
education officials from all across the
state they came up with guidelines that
will say the districts have to have
flexible plans they have to be
safeguards they're prioritizing safety
maximizing available space focusing on
arts career technical education they
have to be innovative how do you use
remote learning how do you use
innovative models best practices and all
the guidelines will be up today we want
masks and PPE whenever students or staff
cannot maintain social distancing masks
were
they work for children they work for
teachers they work for everyone we have
social distancing six feet separations
we have cohort structures in the
guidelines guidelines on transportation
foodservice aftercare extracurricular
activities every child and person
entering will be screened tracing has to
work in the schools cleaning and closure
procedures that's all in the guidelines
and again we've done the health
guidelines State Department of Education
which I do not run it's a separate
agency they'll do the education
guidelines incorporating hours well then
what's the bad news all our numbers are
good our numbers are good bad news is we
have to keep them that way
and there are challenges there are two
threats first is lack of compliance by
New Yorkers we get arrogant we get cocky
where there's warm the numbers are good
I heard the governor he said everything
was good there's nothing to worry about
I never said there's nothing to worry
bad I never said that I said the numbers
are good I worry every day
well you just worry a lot nah I'm not
really worried by Nature the
circumstances caused me to worry we have
to remain compliant and the local
governments have to do their job and
enforce compliance well it's hard with
younger people I understand well some
people don't like to wear a mask I
understand well socially distancing is
difficult I understand we have to do it
if you don't do it the virus will
increase period
period I mean is it I'm not in my
opinion I'm not guessing we know it as a
scientific fact that's the first threat
second is the virus comes to New York
and this is a very real threat and it is
deja vu all over again
the first
federal debacle was losing track of the
virus that was supposed to be in China
and not knowing you'd left China and it
went to Europe and then it came here
from Europe and the federal government
has now admitted this it was one of the
great federal blunders in history cost
thousands of lives in New York and
billions of dollars they just missed it
yeah it was a terrible miss and a
terrible mistake and it's what created
the spike in New York the second federal
mistake is even after everything we went
through they allowed and pushed the
other states to reopen recklessly and
you now have the virus out of control in
other states and it's gonna fly back to
New York
the first mistake brought it from Europe
to New York
the second mistake will bring it from
Georgia to New York and Texas to New
York and Arizona to New York in the 38
states that see the virus going up both
times New York did nothing wrong it was
the federal government that caused our
problem and then frankly wanted to have
nothing to do with the solution they
caused the problem and then they said
you're on your own
literally you have 39 states that are
now seeing the virus increase and come
to New York so we talked about the valve
I talked about the valve the reopening
valve we talked about monitoring it all
along you now have to add two additional
measures or dials to the valve what is
now you have to watch the effect of
non-compliance and make sure the local
governments are doing their job the
second dial is now the effect of the
National outbreak and people coming here
to new
York with the virus those are the two
new complications that have been added
to the mix and look it is the federal
government because it is the federal
government sometimes it is what it is
and this has been gross negligence they
have been denying the reality of the
situation from the beginning it doesn't
exist it's going to go away by Easter
will reopen when it gets warm it will go
away like it's a miracle it didn't go
away
there was no miracle you denied reality
this is their political agenda over
public health policy that's what this is
this is politically inconvenient in an
election year so deny it yeah except you
are jeopardizing public health and
you're losing lives by your denial and
your political agenda and then when the
federal government didn't step up and
handle this this was a federal crisis
why is New York State or the state of
Georgia or the state of California or
any of these states handling the Cova
virus it's a national issue
the President did a federal emergency
declaration you know what a federal
emergency declaration means it means a
federal emergency you know who's in
charge of federal emergencies the
federal government that's why they use
the word federal in all of those
expressions I was in the federal
government when there's a federal
emergency is the responsibility in the
federal government they just abandon
their post and said it's up to the
states and by the way they got offended
when the states asked for any resources
or help
from the federal government if they're
not going to step up and address a
problem that helps every that hurts
every state in the United States then
what is the point of the federal
government I mean if you don't see that
is your role what is the role and now
the president is attacking science what
a surprise
no surprise he's been attacking science
from day one the denial of reality was
to deny science and he's done that from
day one at the end of the day science
Trump's politics politics does not Trump
science you don't defeat a virus with
politics you defeat a virus by using
science and medicine that was true from
day one President now says his own
health officials are lying about the
virus his own CDC health officials are
lying about the virus well if the
president is telling the truth you know
what he should do he should fire them
he should fire them you know what I
would do if I believed my health
commissioner was lying I would fire him
if I said in this room my health
commissioner is lying about the corona
virus you know your first question would
be governor if you say he's lying how do
you not fire him how do you keep him in
charge of health policy if you say the
person is lying because someone is
clearly lying to the American people and
people are dying because of it
Trump's covert scandal makes what Nixon
did at Watergate look innocent
nobody died in the Watergate scandal
thousands of people are going to die in
this covert scandal and that is all the
difference in the world you look at the
facts the facts clearly demonstrate
Trump was wrong from day one and New
Yorkers have been right from day one
there's no argument there's nothing to
tweet about the facts are in the numbers
are in look at the number of bodies look
at the infection rate New York's numbers
have declined while the nation is going
up New York is down 70% these other
states up over 800% Florida up thirteen
hundred percent who's right who's wrong
what's there to argue about those are
the numbers tell me the numbers are
wrong it's all across the country and it
is undeniable in its now a threat to the
state of New York we have done a
quarantine for the highest risk
infection states we know there been
instances of non-compliance
non-compliance can lead to outbreaks
we're seeing it in Rensselaer County now
where people came up from Georgia we're
going to have the Department of Health
issue an emergency health order today
that will mandate that out-of-state
travelers
from the states that a quarantine must
provide a location form before they
leave the airport the airlines will hand
it out on the plane it will also be
available on the web you can fill fill
it out electronically or you have to
fill out the piece of paper on the
airplane
you must give officials at the airport
your form as to where you came from and
where you're going before you leave the
airport it will be enforced in every
airport in the state of New York down
state the Port Authority will enforce it
if you leave the airport without
providing the information you will
receive a summons immediately with a
$2,000 fine
if you leave the airport without filling
out the information not only can you
have a two thousand dollar fine you can
then be brought to a hearing in order to
complete mandatory quarantine okay none
of this is pleasant but we've gone
through this before we went through this
when Rick cotton and people at the Port
Authority watched three million
Europeans people from Europe come into
this state and bringing the virus fool
me once we can't be in a situation where
we are people coming from other states
in the country bringing the virus again
it is that simple
again Port Authority will do the
enforcement in downstate New York the
other airports will do it in upstate New
York the general point is we have to
stay diligent New Yorkers have been
truly amazing and what they did was
historic they tamed the Beast because
they are New York tough which means
smart United disciplined and loving the
facts I now want to give you an opinion
this case it's
very personal opinion personal opinion
but very personal is personal then
there's like very personal which is even
more personal than just personal we went
through 11 days of hell
everybody processed it their own way I
saw it as climbing a mountain and you
had to climb that mountain every day and
every day was hard and every day
climbing the mountain you didn't even
know how high the mountain was and at
the same time you were designing the
mountain because our behavior was going
to design the mountain and design the
plateau and the peak when will the virus
stop when you stop the virus is what the
experts would say to me like a cruel
riddle every day when do the deaths stop
and does the infection rate stop when
you stop it what does that mean when the
socially the social distancing works
when the closed-down policies work when
the masks work you're climbing a
mountain and you were designing the
curve of the map it ends when you say it
ends right this was traumatizing for
people and on a personal level economic
level it was frightening it was
isolating everyone had their own demons
they were dealing with I had my own
demons and my own fears I'm afraid from
my mother afraid from my kids afraid
from my brother everyone had their own
pain and their own trauma to deal with
but what we went through and we did was
this hard because we did tame the beast
we did turn the corner we did plateau
that mountain and we came down the other
side and they will be talking about what
we did for decades to come
it really was an historic moment
personally traumatic socially traumatic
and historic so I love history I love
poster art poster art is something they
did in the early 1900's late 1800s when
they had to communicate the whole
platform candidacy on one piece of paper
right he wanted to run a campaign they
didn't have the TV commercials they
didn't have mail they didn't have any of
these things so they got their whole
message on one piece of paper and it
always fascinated me I use so many words
what if somebody said okay no words
paint me a picture that tells the story
of what you're trying to say that's
poster art and it's helped me because
it's been like a relief valve not that I
don't have joy every day dealing with
you guys but I could go and just use a
different side of my brain and this was
the most famous the William Jennings
Bryan with the octopus he's fighting the
octopus and the octopus is corporate
trusts that are taking over the economy
right you could almost do that again
today so over the past few years I've
done my own posters on that capture that
feeling I did this one for the state of
the state
ship of state that was sailing in this
sea of division right back in January
well in any event so I didn't know what
for what we went through with Kovac and
I think the general shape is familiar to
to you we went up the mountain we curve
the mountain we came down the other side
and these are little telltale signs that
to me represent what was going on
that big arrow that goes right up
through it that was the economic models
right we needed a hundred and twenty
thousand beds we needed one hundred and
forty thousand beds and those models
shot straight up
we had to bend the curve despite those
models we needed 30 thousand ventilators
that model said we almost get to the top
of the mountain economy Falls get it
economy falls like Niagara Falls but
then then the economy drops the economy
Falls and the economy comes running down
timeline on the bottom from day one to
day 111 it's roughly scaled and then
little visuals of what was going on
starts on day one little octopus is the
tailback to the William Jennings Bryan
poster Zach got that right away
first Kahn's on a cruise ship the covert
virus right we start the daily briefings
it's Jim Morris and Stephanie Benton
hand sanitizer if the winds of fear or
blowing everybody's afraid we have the
plane p3 begin people from Europe and
that's how Kovac came through the clouds
of the federal government CDC etc
testing hospital surge Javits Center
we're pulling down the curve together
right 111 days of hell the New Rochelle
hot spot first hot spot cluster testing
tracing nasal swab cute little button
nose I'm driving once again one of the
few benefits of this I get to drive
myself now subway disinfection we've
turned the corner mask up social
distancing
the Sun is on the other side of the
mountain we just had to make it to the
other side of the mountain there's the
man in the moon it's just the flu phase
one we're now coming down the other side
boyfriend cliff is there tell the people
the truth they will do the right thing
they made the boyfriend look like that
think I'm not sure why who's pulling
down the curve New Yorkers health care
workers the essential workers out of
state volunteers 30,000 people from out
of state volunteer to come help us I
have my three daughters there that's
Captain to have him a little paunchy
he's on a diet he's not that bad but
he's on his way
stock market reopens we come down the
other side
there's the briefing table out of state
ban follow the facts Sara zona Texas
Florida going up last little sign
caution ahead caution ahead we climbed
the mountain with down the mountain be
cautious what we're talking about today
do compliance watch people from other
states and we're still in the sea of
division which I talked about in January
worse George Floyd murder racial tension
protests even worse
that was so New York tough smart United
disciplined loving in case you haven't
heard that before because love wins at
the end of the day love is the rainbow
timeline on the bottom we forged
community and community wins and you
were part of it and I'm going to give
you a poster because you were part of
interval
no workers don't have to self quarantine
when they come back I'm an essential
worker I think I'm gonna central work
some people would say I'm not that
essentially yes you can follow the
number that's what's nice about this
there's no politics there's no personal
opinion there's no very look at the
number you're one person okay as long as
you don't go over five you have a green
light if you see two three if it's a
consistent basis and start the word
because if the numbers going up and if
the number goes over five you hit the
red emergency button so if you see two
three four yeah you're probably headed
for five unless you do something very
dramatic the incorrect I don't know what
you said so I have no comment on what
you said but people are theories an
incorrect Theory doesn't wind up being
correct because there's a void
and I think we have been talking about
what's going on I don't think there is
one answer but I think you raised a good
point last week I think there are a
number of contributing factors and you
put all those factors together and
that's what you're seeing going on it's
a one fact during that's why it's a
little more complicated you know in
politics they want to be able to say
it's just this it's not just this there
are a number of factors but I don't
think you know you have violent crime
which is murder etc more than robbery
you know I think if the the violent
crimes have been more drug related etc
the fact yeah on the rent issue
specifically though as I'm sure you all
remember the governor did an executive
order back in March that said there
couldn't be any evictions on commercial
or residential rent through June we then
extended that for anyone who is covert
hardship related through the end of
August in the interim the Legislature
passed legislation that said that you
can't be up for any rent evictions
during this crisis which is a bill that
we signed I think week and a half ago
and so I'm not sure how it could Square
that it's people that are concerned like
not able to pay the rent when right now
there are no evictions on the table
legally so yeah it is factually
impossible that somebody committed a
crime so they could pay their rent if
you can't pay your rent you cannot be
evicted right now
specifically one of the issues they used
the publicly reported data and the curve
shows what the curves to David the facts
are the facts so I think it didn't
material impact the overall outcome
which was the timing of the fatalities
happened well before any of the emission
policy that the work force itself was a
driving factor because that's when the
infection came in early on so those
material facts would not be changed one
way or another but we're basing it on
the public the department felt was
missing on the public data that
everybody has its weight you count if
the person goes into the hospital as is
were in the hospital because that a
hospitalization death as opposed to
trying to trace every from how long did
the person have to be from the nursing
home into the hospital or you'd have to
do the other way back it out of the
hospital deaths increase the nursing
home and reduce the hospitalization but
you know you two numbers together it's
the number how much progress has New
York hospitals made how does that seven
statements work time we also know about
that the consortium is more of a
longer-term production mode if you put
those states together can we manufacture
our own and is there's one state have
the capacity to manufacture masks and
once they'd have the capacity
manufacturer gowns and one state of the
capacity manufacturer the reagents for
the testing etc the 90-day PPE is going
to be a firm regulation they must have
90 days of PPE in supply period there's
no wiggle room on that we gave them a
period of time to ramp up
there's a cash flow issue storage issue
etc but everybody has to have 90 days of
PPE in their own stockpile lesson
learned and that's a stay brick they
should have 90 days on hand now or they
would have had to get a waiver from the
Department of Health because they didn't
have the cash flow or something like
that but I've not heard of anyone
getting a waiver and just in the
government's point and it's the 90 days
at the highest burn rate which was the
requirement at the so like it's the peak
of a new way but something like that and
we're tracking this many of the
hospitals we track the visionary as well
have more than 90 days they've actually
gone extra cautious some have 120 days
worth of materials so we're tracking all
of that I don't know of any waivers
either but we'll check on that that not
applies act the testing equipment that
was only Hospital PP
yeah I don't think the state funding
formula is goes by legislation now it's
a set formula for every school district
in the in the state 700 school districts
I don't think there's any variance in
the law that would allow you to shift
funds from one school district to
another on the death rate of course they
say look it's it is very very good news
that's why I literally say
congratulations to New Yorkers
we followed the data we have a model
that work and worked all across the
state it is working we are reopening the
other regions outside of New York or
even further down the road on reopening
and the numbers are all good yes we have
compliance issues especially downstate
New York and Long Island but it's been
great news I want to look ahead
it was just today I'd say great all
great but we've all learned the hard way
look ahead what's the next shoe that
could drop I'm worried about people
coming to New York you are not a
hermetically sealed bubble right
somebody lands in New York they come
through Ric's Airport they come through
JFK LaGuardia Newark Airport I remember
the first positive we had was a health
worker coming back through the airport
and I remember what that started the
first case what oberg did she get into
what did who who would the gate did she
say hello to where did she picked up her
bag what uber driver who did she egg
shake hands with in their hotel lobby
you know it
it came in through the airports it will
come in through the airports once again
to the retail locations if you believe
this eventually it could but the air
filtration to me you know when we talk
about being smart right what have we
done in New York
we've been smart but because we're we're
smart and common-sense look at
everything you can this air filtration
is a major function it's not the most
sexy of functions and you won't hear
many governor's talking about air
filters you but you are the filter that
can filter out the COBIT virus Wow
why aren't you using it we then ran into
all sorts of complications this HVAC
system fits at this dozen etc but we put
out guidance the hepa filter is the best
of those systems that can take it
otherwise you have to have a merv 13 for
a large congregate setting is the best
or down to of merv 11 that's the floor
and the ceiling if you will but I'm
excited about the possibility and we'll
see how it goes
if the infection rate stays down then
you're going to see us continue to
increase the capacity and if the air
filtration is one of those devices that
keeps the infection rate down great
sorry yeah we're talking to a few states
and we're seeing what they need and the
best way to get it
yeah I don't know what you're listening
to what they're saying or what it
actually means
so we'll see what guidance they put out
at the end of the day and with their sir
you
it was an uptick in the availability of
illegal guns is there have been heard
and I would just cotton last week it was
fail reform and it was the chokehold ban
and it was bikers and then it's rent and
now it's this I think that this is a
really complex issue that is really
incredibly important to the safety of
the people of New York and that people
should refrain from tossing around
theories with I would ask Governor Cuomo
did you really design that poster or did
somebody just design that poster was
that really you or did somebody else do
that I would say if the answering is me
I would say yes I designed it I resent
that question I don't like the
implication of it I think it was
personally derogatory and hostile so yes
I said I designed it because I designed
it what would I ask Andrew Cuomo
separating him from Governor Cuomo I
would ask Andrew Cuomo how are you doing
through all of this and when you look
back what you think on a personal level
I would say that's a personal question
and I think it's inappropriate to ask me
at this
you and I'd get a little defensive and
then I would say I think at the end of
the day we will actually be stronger as
a society for what we went through I
think my family is stronger as a family
for what we went through I would say it
was the hardest thing I've ever done in
my life I think the hardest thing a lot
of New Yorkers did but I think I am
stronger for it I think my family is
stronger for it I think we're stronger
for it as a society on the theory that
that which doesn't kill you makes you
stronger I bet we never have to go
through it again and I hope this nation
gets the message and those other states
get the message so we save lives in this
country and if they follow what New York
did we will save lives and nothing is
more important than that
thank you guys thank you very much
[Music]